Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
They just released an Invincible Season
2 bonus episode
that's meant to be a prequel to season
two, episode one.
there's a whole bunch of back story
and Easter eggs
that will be important for what happens
during season two and beyond.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I'll do videos for all the season
two episodes this season.
I only did the finale for season one.
they also just released
the season two trailer.
I already did a bigger video about that
so I'll add the link
for that at the end of this
and down in the description below.
careful for spoilers for that
bonus episode if you haven't seen it yet.
It's on Amazon right now,
just like the normal episodes.
They released it late last night
when they released the Season two trailer.
little surprise.
We made an entire episode
that you can watch right now.
You should have died at birth.
the episode is mostly meant to tell Atom
Eve's origin story
and give some more backstory
and context on on the man's relationship
with Invincible
because On Demand continues
to be a big character
during the entire run of the Invincible
series,
he'll still be
a very important character in the story
right up
until the very final episodes,
whichever season that way ends up being.
the already
working on season three right now.
They haven't renewed for season four yet,
but they will eventually.
They could go beyond season five.
They want to.
so just because he took off
at the end of season
one doesn't
mean he's completely gone from the story.
He is back during season two.
the other major reasons why they did this
Atom Eve story is both because it's
a big spin off in the comics,
but more importantly,
it provides a lot of context
for why she does
a lot of what she does later in the series
when she becomes an even bigger character
and both she and Invincible
go through some super WITF things
together, as their relationship
gets more and more complicated.
they use her origin story
in all the super messed up stuff
that happened to her as a kid
to provide more context for why she makes
some of the really hard choices
that she does later in the story, mostly
with respect to her
an invincibles relationship.
So not going to get too much into that
because it's later in the story.
but just in general
if you thought the season one was messed
up, that's only an appetizer.
Things only get crazier
and bigger later in the story.
they barely even touch on that
in the season two trailer.
Like most of the trailer only covers
what happens at the beginning
of season two
with like a very brief teaser
for things like Thaddeus,
which is a little bit later in the story.
what I'll do is I'll start
with the invincible omni-man stuff
in the episode since it was pretty brief.
And then I'll talk about the Atom
Eve stuff,
but the episode takes place
over a few different time periods.
It picks up with Omni-Man
Just as Invincible
is getting ready to be born
because he and Atom
Eve are about the same age
during the season two trailer
when they're doing their high school
graduation at Reginald Vale Johnson
High School, Reginald Bell Johnson
in real life is voicing the principal
who is a version of himself
in the invincible universe
that just became a principal. alternate
universe.
Carl Winslow just became a principal
instead of being an actor.
you see them all sitting there
like Atom Eve
is sitting with the rest of their friends
at their high school
graduation, which Invincible is missing
because he's out on missions
So while you're seeing her be born,
Invincible is about to be born as well.
the story picks up with the Lizard League,
who you saw during season one attacking
the research and development
arm of Global Defense Agency,
trying to steal Advanced Tech.
If it wasn't clear the lab were Atom
eve and her brothers, quote unquote,
were created
the same place where Cecil works
and shows all those things
to Invincible at the end of season one.
it was the same group that commissioned
this experiment for the creation of Atom
Eve, even though at the time
Cecil wasn't working there,
he doesn't work there
until much later in the timeline
the Lizard League, were there
for totally different reasons.
They were just trying
to steal random tech.
They had no idea
Atom eve existed, and Tatiana maslany,
who just played She-Hulk
in the Marvel Universe.
She's also played
a bunch of other characters too.
You probably remember
is the voice of the Lizard Queen.
Her son is voiced by Jacob Tremblay.
If you saw the crazy number of huge actors
that they teased
for season two during the trailer,
some of them show up during this prequel,
meaning that they will come back
and present day during season two.
Phil Lamarr here is playing Salamander,
who's done a billion animated characters
in different series.
He's also played a lot of DC
animated characters as well.
most of all, the invincible characters
are meant to be parodies of DC characters
like the Guardians of the Globe
are basically their version of the Justice
League Omni-Man is basically
like a dark version of Superman,
The Guardians wind up showing up.
The reason their costumes are different
is because this is happening
about 18 years ago in the timeline
the team at that time
had Black Samson on it.
He winds up leaving the team
after he loses his powers.
Later, and then most of the team
gets killed by Omni-Man
during the events of season one
and they have to reform it.
With Black Samson coming back to the team.
He's voiced by Corey Payton.
There are many Walking Dead actors
that played characters during this,
like War Woman is played by Lauren Cohan,
also from The Walking Dead, Maggie
Jeffrey, Dean Morgan
is probably going to wind up playing thragg
Look like they teased the Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is joining the series.
I think that he's going to wind up being
threatened when he eventually shows up.
So if you recognize a lot of Walking Dead
actors, that's why it's Robert Kirkman,
because Robert Kirkman
created The Walking Dead,
they reference a bunch of other characters
that work with the guardians
that aren't there, like dark
wing Martian man, Red Rush, Dark Blood,
who all show up during season one.
And later in the story
they make a couple references
to the concept
that Omni-Man is a reservist,
but he refuses to be on the team.
like there's some beef between Omni-Man
and some of the members of the team,
which is just them ceding the idea
that eventually Omni-Man will kill them.
He plans to kill them eventually.
that was the reason why he never joined
any of the other superhero teams,
which he says later it's because he always
knew that he would have to kill them.
So we wanted to just keep them at arm's
length as much as possible.
but every once in a while,
he does show up to help out
like he does
at the beginning of this episode.
Just because
he wants to keep up appearances.
So the world will think
that he's a superhero,
even though he's playing a long con.
the joke about his original costume
not being flashy enough for him is him
changing from his original filter to my
military suit that was just pure white.
That's a standard military suit
that they all wear.
Changing into the special omni-man suit
when he started calling himself Omni-Man,
which is created by Art Rosenbaum that we
saw in season one, played by Mark Hamill,
the whole thing about not being iconic
enough in walking around with a letter on
your chest
is meant to be both a superman joke
and a dig at the Immortal,
who has a large eye on his chest.
you could also call that a joke
about Image Comics, like the I for Image
Comics, because Robert Kirkman was one
of the major founders of Image Comics.
we see the events of Atom Eve's birth.
She was designed
by the Global Defense Agency specifically
to become the ultimate super weapon,
being capable of manipulating
subatomic matter at the molecular level.
Her mother,
which is a random homeless woman that
areas Brandi were found for their program,
manipulating her amniotic fluid during her
pregnancy to give her the powers
some of you
might recognize some similarities
to Homelander's origin story on the boys
because it's fairly similar.
when he was being born.
They dosed his fetus
with a ton of compound B and they both
why they're killing their mothers
because their mothers are totally normal
and not capable of carrying superhero
children.
Technically,
she doesn't wind up killing her mother,
though,
as we find super messed up story there.
Brandi worth boy ends up
having to cut the child from her womb
in, spare her from a life.
Growing up as a lab rat
in the Global Defense Agency.
they pass her off as the baby
that another couple
just lost who think that Atom Eve
is their natural born daughter,
even though she eventually learns
the truth they show you her early life,
how she starts to figure out
how her powers work.
As he comes into them,
she can manipulate subatomic matter
in any way that she wants,
both organic and inorganic.
But during her early life, Brandi Worth
said that he created a subconscious mental
block preventing her
from messing with organic matter.
but it's just meant to be a mental thing.
She can eventually overcome that.
Eventually,
she does come into the full extent
of her powers
a couple times throughout the series,
but it takes extreme trauma in order
for her to overcome that mental block.
That happens briefly
at the very end of this episode,
when Steven Erickson,
played by the late Lance Reddick, R.I.P.,
killed her real mother in Brain Worth
using the full extent of her powers.
She manipulates organic matter of his body
to wipe his memory and almost changes
his entire body.
But eventually she passes out
and when she comes to again,
the mental block is back.
So it's not a permanent thing.
later on in the story,
we'll see something similar happen again
where she goes through
multiple traumatic events,
like when Conquest shows up and she can
briefly overcome that mental block again.
So she'll continue to get more
and more powerful.
Erickson is the main villain
for this part of the story.
He's just meant to be a project manager
working for the Global Defense Agency
at this time.
but at this point, like I said,
Cecil hasn't started to work there.
Eventually
he winds up running the entire place
and they continue to do
kind of messed up stuff like this.
if you wonder the reason why Omni-Man
let them escape to the hospital with Atom Eve
but she was being born is because
he doesn't really care about Atom Eve.
He just assumes that he's
the most powerful person on the planet.
There's nothing
or no one that can challenge him,
so he just gets a lot of stuff
slide like this all the time.
remember, he's
also trying to keep up appearances
at this point, playing the long con.
So he's pretty careful
about the way that he acts in public.
later in the timeline,
Brandi Wirth is replaced by Rogers,
who continues the experiments.
but without Brandi Worth, they revealed
they're not able to perfectly replicate
the experiment.
So they wind up with a bunch of failures.
the reveal that they took Atom
Eve's mother's body,
from the operating room
and resuscitated as much as possible,
but she was brain dead
to create more superpowered children
trying to replicate
that original experiment.
so. When her brother calls them
her family, that's meant to be literal.
They are biologically all her brothers.
She winds up being forced to kill
and they're all kept in Stacy's
tanks next to the barely alive
body of her real mother.
super messed up. Super wtf.
This will all be important for Atom
Eve's character development
and her relationship
with Invisible later in the timeline.
Like if you wonder why she's so reticent
about having a relationship
with Invisible,
you just
look at this episode in her back story
and you understand like, Oh, I get it.
when she starts testing her powers
and goes up against kill can
and he returns later during season
one, The burger restaurant where they eat
later is the same burger place
where Invincible winds up working
just before his powers come in.
They also feature it during the Season
two teaser trailer
where he was buying lunch
for Alan the Alien.
if you remember that season two teaser
trailer they released a little while ago.
There was actually a
scene of the two of them much earlier
in the timeline,
sitting next to present Day Invincible
with Alan the Alien.
So it was like
they were teasing this episode, dropping,
even though these two scenes
are just combined into the same scene,
they're happening in different parts
of the timeline.
this is sort of like the big belly burger
of the invincible universe.
They also reveal that Brandi Worth found
Atom Eve's real mother, homeless, living
behind the restaurant,
which makes the fact
that she's eating here
now that much more messed up.
Of course he lies to her about that part.
Like he doesn't tell her
that her mother was a homeless person.
Mostly
to make her feel better about herself.
She's already got enough problems.
Like he didn't
want to lay the total truth on her,
that her mother was just a random
homeless person that they exploited.
when she starts fighting and accidentally
killing her brothers.
Rogers and Erickson
actually wanted that to happen.
They were just using her brothers
as cannon fodder to draw her out
so that they could either capture her
or force her to come back to the lab.
you notice when she makes herself
that armor, it's kind of Green Lantern
inspired armor because we're talking about
DC character parodies here.
She's using similar powers
like Green Lantern.
Lab learned the truth about her mother
losing both her and Brandy.
Worth wipes Erickson's mind
using her biological powers
that she overcame the mental block
to get that ultimately winds up
going back to her kind of abusive
father and well-meaning,
but also kind of bad mother.
she does keep the picture
of her real family, which he transmutes.
So she has that in present day.
But the idea is that the episode ends
with her staying with those parents
because for now, as she says
in the episode, they're all she's got.
part of the idea, though,
is that Invincible winds up becoming that
feel like the family that you make
for yourself, winds up being more powerful
than the family
that you're kind of born into.
Even though technically
she wasn't born into this family either.
She was also adopted by them,
even though her entire story
is super track like she's a tragic back
story and super messed up
stuff happens to her through season
to season three, season four and beyond.
Eventually,
there is a more hopeful ending for her
character, so don't worry, without
getting into too many spoilers about that.
But things are only going to get worse
for her before they get better.
The idea, though, is
that she stays with those parents.
And when season one picks up, she's
been in high school for a little while.
when we meet her
during the events of season one
with the regular episodes pickup,
she's already been doing regular superhero
work for a while,
but she was still living with those same
adoptive parents at the time, eventually
leaving those parents permanently
during the events of season one.
the reason
this is all important for season
two and beyond Season three, Season four.
Like I said, the trauma
she experienced as a child,
what happened in the lab
with a real mother,
her brothers makes her super
against ever having a family of her own.
She doesn't want to have children
for obvious reasons.
so as her relationship
with Invincible grows and they get closer,
things get super complicated without
getting too far ahead of the story.
She makes some really, really hard
choices.
Later on. It gets super crazy.
So no spoilers for that.
But the comics are out there.
If you want to read ahead in the comics,
you can do that right now.
actual end of the episode
is in the Omni-Man tag scene.
Remember,
Invincible is the same age as Atom
Eve though he's about 12 years old
in this scene here, joking
that he'll never get his powers.
But after his mother goes upstairs
to rip the duct tape off of him
and that's going to hurt Briefly.
You see Omni-Man flash rage on his face
like he's right about to kill
both of them,
until he realizes that he loves his son,
even though he's unsure
if his mission
will ultimately be a failure
and he won't get his powers,
meaning that he would have to start
a completely different family
and try again with another son.
this is here because they want to
remind you why he didn't kill Invincible
at the end of season one,
because ultimately he loves him,
even though the story's mostly meant
to follow
the invincible character,
like his name is the name of the series.
The entire story is also kind of
like the redemption of Omni-Man
is sort of like the Star Wars
original trilogy,
where you see Darth Vader
doing all these evil things,
but then you learn
about his tragic backstory
and eventually he winds up
redeeming himself Omni-Man eventually does
turn good and try to help Mark
take down drag in the Build Termites.
But that's much later in the story.
will start to get into that
during season two.
Like you'll start to see his character
turn.
That's the main reason
why he's back in season two.
But he's not a super big character again
till later in the story Overall,
it was a great episode.
Is there any other big Easter eggs
or references
that you spotted
that I didn't mention in the video?
Just write them below in the comments
in my full season.
Two episodes will start later this year
when they premiere,
but I'll do more bonus videos
when we get more trailers for the series
because we're in the middle of Comic-Con
week.
There'll be a bunch more trailers
and things this weekend.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss those.
I'll try to do videos for everything.
Click here for that new Invincible Season
2 trailer and click here
for all my Comic-Con trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!